president joe biden has confirmed that
he is going to go ahead and re-nominate
fed chairman jerome powell for a second
term as many of you already know the fed
chair is an appointed position it's not
an elected position that means that the
president and his administration is
responsible for going ahead and saying
this is who i want to go ahead and
propose to run the federal reserve the
central bank of the united states there
then is a confirmation process that they
go through in order to be confirmed as
that specific role now jerome powell was
appointed under president trump's
administration he's
the united states central bank over the
covid crisis as we know back in march of
2020 there was a liquidity crisis in
financial markets especially here in the
united states government ordered
everyone to go sit at home in their
homes there was uncertainty there was
fear and so what did people do they sold
off all of their financial assets when
they did that the dollar strength and
asset prices fell very very quickly we
saw public equities dropped 25 30 we saw
gold go down about 15 bitcoin went down
50 in a single day when you get a
liquidity crisis you can do one of two
things you can either choose not to
intervene you can allow the free market
to try to correct itself you can say hey
we're not going to step in here or the
central bank and say you know what we
have to intervene we have to mitigate
the short-term pain and that is exactly
what they did they issued two emergency
interest rate cuts all the way down to
zero percent interest rate environment
they flooded the market with cheap
capital they heavily incentivized people
to go borrow as much as they possibly
could and push that liquidity into the
market on top of that they had their
hand in providing quantitative easing
doing all sorts of different purchases
in financial markets the fed's balance
sheet since 2009 has gone from about 900
billion dollars to now over 8 trillion
dollars almost a 10 bagger in about 12
years and so ultimately what we saw was
all of that intervention all of that
financial stimulus that was pushed into
the market over the last 12 to 18 months
has given rise to one still over four
and a half percent unemployment in the
united states which is one of the
mandates of the federal reserve it's
full employment they have not met the
full employment on top of that the
second mandate is stable prices they
should keep prices stable but because we
are now living multiple months with over
five percent inflation last month's
inflation number was 6.2 percent on a
cpi basis the fed has failed at both
full employment and also stable prices
now their argument would be we had to do
it we had to mitigate the short-term
pain we had to flood the market with
lots and lots of liquidity in order to
make sure that americans were okay and
we made a direct trade-off between
mitigating short-term pain for the
medium to long-term pain that we would
have to address at a later date now the
problem is from the critics of the
federal reserve is that yes maybe you
had to do it maybe you didn't but we
told you that there was going to be high
levels of inflation you said that don't
worry about it there won't be and now we
have over six percent cpi it's the
official number the core inflation
number not including food and energy is
over four percent almost four and a half
percent and the unofficial number is in
the double digits and so ultimately what
you have to start to think about is that
essentially is a report card for the
chairman of the federal reserve now as i
have talked about over and over again in
the past i do not believe that who the
person is as the federal reserve
chairman would have mattered i don't
think that jerome powell did a good or
bad job i think he did exactly what he
had to do which is what anyone else in
that position would have been uh forced
to do regardless of the monetary policy
regardless of the theoretics around the
economic arguments this was much more of
a social argument we need help we need
help we need help bring help to the
people and so everyone from those who
had no clue what's going on all the way
up to the most sophisticated people
financial markets they were cheering on
the stimulus they wanted it they needed
it people were running to the government
saying please help me please help me and
the federal reserve was there to fill
that need both through the interest rate
manipulation down to zero and also the
quantitative easing so regardless of
whether it was your own power or anybody
else i think they would have done this
and so i do not think that you can
assign good or bad decision making on
the federal reserve chairman because
ultimately anyone would have done the
same thing in that position doesn't make
it right doesn't mean that it was in
hindsight the best decision but it does
mean that anyone would have done it
given the facts we had at the time so
ultimately there is probably no need to
replace him because he's doing the best
that he can now as i've talked about in
the past also is if the system is
designed in a way where they are going
to continue to do this they're going to
continue to be debase the currency
they're going to continue to manipulate
interest rates then you as an individual
investor complaining is irrelevant
complaining will not solve your problems
complaining is the mark of a loser
instead what you should do is you should
figure out how to invest regardless of
what financial markets you invest in
that is going to be your best path to
providing some level of financial
security for yourself and for your
family so whether you want to invest in
stock market whether you want to invest
in commodities whether you want to
invest in bitcoin or other crypto assets
learning how to invest is essential if
you want to protect your purchasing
power in today's economic environment so
ultimately regardless of the fed
chairman is you are going to have to
learn to invest don't worry about who's
in charge don't worry about what their
policies are because you i my brothers
and nobody else is going to change their
mind they're going to continue to do
what they do you just need to learn how
to invest so that you can position
yourself to benefit rather than be
punished by these decisions we've
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
in this country as do many countries
around the world that is because they
are backed into a corner they have no
other choice and so if you want to
benefit from that undisciplined decision
making then you need to be an investor
over the last 12 to 18 months the
wealthy the top 55 of americans who hold
investable assets they have gotten
richer and richer and richer they are
richer than they ever imagined because
they simply got long financial assets
and the currency was debased at a
historic rate and that pushed asset
prices up literally this morning the s p
500 hit another all-time high shocking
people love jerome powell they love the
money printer and they love the fact
that stocks continue to hit all-time
high after all-time high simply because
the currency is being debased now if you
are not one of the 55 percent of people
who hold investable assets and instead
you have zero investment assets to the
bottom 45 of americans you have been
punished over and over and over again
you are getting paid less money today
than you were 12 months ago and on top
of that you also have less purchasing
power in your savings than you did 12
months ago as well so you can't save you
have to invest and also you better be
asking for a big raise at work whether
you are an hourly wage worker or your
salaried worker you have to go in you
have to say inflation's at six percent
if i don't receive a six plus percent uh
raised then i literally am getting paid
less this year than i was last year and
that's not fair you need to combat
inflation at a minimum in order for me
to be able to keep up with the
purchasing power that i observe